la voie pacifique qui est évidemment le
grand problème là les très grands
problèmes de ce temps on me signale que
l'interview de madame françoise giroud
cela permettait à la condition féminine
réalisé par jacques incoming peut
maintenant passer sur vos écrans
la voici il s'agit de l'année 1975 année
internationale de la fin l'onu a décidé
que cette année sera l'année
internationale de la femme pourquoi
cette année à votre avis est-ce que
c'est parce que tout d'un coup tout le
monde a pris conscience des problèmes de
la situation des femmes non se croient
pas vous savez chaque année l'onu
déclare qu'il y à l'année de la
population l'année de ceci ou de cela
cette année les femmes peut-être parce
que c'est un peu la mode mais pas dans
le sens péjoratif du terme c'est aussi
positif que ce soit la mode c'est vrai
qu'il y à une prise de conscience de la
situation des femmes en particulier aux
états unis où que vous savez il ya même
des révoltes assez vive dans la
population féminine et que se trouve que
le siège des nations unies est à new
york par conséquent ceux qui le dirigent
donc d'être été particulièrement
sensible d'autre part c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu en france un phénomène qui a été
ressenti en général dans le monde entier
mais enfin l'année internationale de la
femme a été décrétée avant je crois
aussi que dans des pays en voie de
développement
quelque chose se passe de ce côté là
mais probablement c'est pourquoi l'on
beaucoup moins sensible qu'en europe et
aux états unis parce qu'on ne peut tout
de même pas comparer la situation des
femmes dans tous les pays du monde
s'appuie sous-développés la situation
n'est pas la même du tube dans nos pays
elle n'est pas la même du tout eu on
peut la comparer seulement parce qu'il
ya tout de même un phénomène mondial qui
est la revendication féminine vers
l'égalité
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
cette année internationale peut
présenter quelque intérêt d'ailleurs
c'est précisément la comparaison entre
ce qui se passe dans les différents pays
même niveau ce que vous même vous êtes
secrétaire d'état à la condition
féminine vous avez découvrir des choses
que vous ne connaissiez pas vous
n'auriez pas soupçonner au cou je
n'aurais pas soupçonner non je ne peux
pas dire en gros je n'ai rien découvert
j'ai découvert naturellement un certain
nombre de choses en détails en
particulier dans la législation dans les
textes administratifs dans certaines
conditions féminines que je connaissais
très mal
par exemple la condition des femmes
rurales comme beaucoup de parisiens
je connais mal la campagne pour moi la
campagne c'était autre chose et j'ai
découvert là une catégorie femme tout à
fait remarquable intelligente et qui ont
la prochaine un problème très très
particulière et très très tonique
d'ailleurs et puis j'ai découvert peux
pas dire que j'ai découvert j'ai
constaté qu'il y avait encore un petit
peu plus d'injustice que je ne le
pensais
dans la condition des femmes à travers
les textes et c'est d'ailleurs cette
injustice que j'essaie de réduire
est ce que justement si les femmes
s'occuper un peu plus de politique il
n'y aurait pas une amélioration plus
rapide les femmes ne font pas beaucoup
de politiques en france pourquoi votre
avis écoutez ça dépend ce que vous
appelez faire de la politique c'est vrai
qu'en général les femmes ne font pas
beaucoup de politiques d'abord que s'il
n'y a pas tellement longtemps qu'elle
vote et parce qu'il faut bien une
génération ou deux pour se mettre à
s'intéresser aux problèmes politiques
si certains sont un peu sceptiques par
rapport à la politique ou plus
exactement elle ne voit pas bien le
rapport qu'il ya entre ce qu'on appelle
la politique et leurs problèmes concrets
quotidien mais elle commence à le voir
et en particulier le voit toutes celles
qui ont une activité municipale
c'est à travers la mairie laisse la cité
la commune que l'on comprend ce que
c'est que la politique le rapport de la
politique et la vie quotidienne
c'est très important et de ce côté là il
ya un progrès il ya pas mal de femmes
qui ont commencé à s'intéresser à
l'activité municipale qui sont
conseillères municipales même
conseillère générale et il y a tout de
même ce n'est pas énorme mais enfin il
ya tout de même près de 700 femmes mères
en france sinon ils n'auraient pas
encore qu'ils soient verts d'une très
grande ville mais enfin c'est déjà un
progrès ça il y en a peu comme quelles
responsabilités importantes dans les
partis politiques par exemple l'un des
partis politiques pas du tout alors là
c'est l'attitude des hommes
il faut bien dire en ce qui concerne la
politique les milieux politiques ne sont
pas particulièrement favorable aux
femmes
encore que là les choses aient l'air
d'être en train de changer le fait qu'il
y ait quatre femmes au gouvernement dont
peut-être un peut-être modifier certains
comportements même pas peut-être a
certainement modifier certains
comportements
ce n'est pas un privilège que l'on ait
sera monsieur giscard d'estaing c'est
bien évident donc là il ya quelque chose
de positif mais nous avons un système
électoral qui n'est pas favorable à
l'action des femmes à la
la députation le système du souhaité un
arrondissement fait qu'il est très
personnalisé et quand il ya une bonne
circonscription les dirigeants
politiques disent vas pas la donne et
une femme parce qu'on ne sait jamais si
nous ne faisait perdre quand elle est
mauvaise on y envoie une femme elle est
battu et on dit vous voyez bien quand on
voit une femme elle est battue par
conséquent le système est largement
responsable
la preuve en est que après la libération
nous avions un système différent qu'on
appelait les scrutins buste qu'on peut
aimer ou pas mais pour d'autres raisons
mais à ce moment là il ya eu beaucoup
plus de femmes à l'assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui
est ce que si plus de femmes avaient des
responsabilités politiques ça changerait
quelque chose dans les politiques par
exemple dans la politique internationale
on peut penser que ça changerait quelque
chose si elle était en nombre suffisant
pour n'avoir pas à copier les attitudes
masculine c'est à dire si elle pouvait
introduire quelque chose de
spécifiquement féminin qu'est-ce qui est
spécifiquement kubina ça c'est une autre
histoire
je pense néanmoins que des femmes
entrant en grand nombre dans les centres
de décision changerait quelque chose et
je l'espère pour le mieux
vous croyez passera de 1000 elle qui
liront par lettre mes suggestions dans
les fautes très patiente se plaint il
semble vivre tout ça ce soit une
question de mentalité changement de
mentalité n'est ce pas est ce que vous
croyez qu'avec les textes législatifs
que vous préparez vous pouvez changer
quelque chose
écoutez bien sûr c'est une question de
changement de mentalité mais le fait que
des lois soient proposés par un
gouvernement voter par un parlement
ça signifie déjà qu'il ya changement de
mentalité ce niveau là donc c'est
extrêmement important pour l'ensemble
d'un pays il ya quelque chose de
contagieux il exemple bien sûr doit
venir d'en haut comment pouvez-vous
enfin d'euros parce qu'il se trouve que
les gouvernements sont dans une
hiérarchie en eau et comment voulez-vous
demander aux gens de changer de
mentalité si nous de changer d'attitude
disons si cette attitude n'est pas
d'abord adopté par des gens qui sont
responsables
l'an passé tout de même parce que
certaines personnes refusent et encore
refuse encore oui je pense qu'il est
entendu voix pour toutes que le rôle de
la femme n'est pas
de nourrir les enfants n'est pas vais
faire vivre le foyer
on sait pas très bien ce que c'est que
le rôle de la femme en dehors du fait
que mais les enfants au monde
il ya donc une redéfinition de ce rôle
et bien sûr à travers les aigles siècle
un poids s'est créé deux cultures
d'habitude et de tradition c'est ça
qu'il faut essayer de changer mais de
changer pas parce que des traductions
sont forcément de mauvaises ou parce que
notre culture est mauvaise le changer
parce que ce n'est plus adapté une
situation nouvelle
quand on fait l'inventaire des problèmes
féminins il semble bien que ce soit une
suite de cas particuliers alors donc
deux solutions individuelles
est-ce qu'on fait encore parler de
condition féminine au milieu de tous ces
cas là je ne suis pas du tout votre avis
pardonnez moi je crois qu'il ya quelque
chose de commun à la condition féminine
et qui est la situation de dépendance et
que ce qui est visé rechercher d'une
façon plus ou moins précises plus ou
moins délibéré c'est précisément
l'indépendance c'est à dire qu'est ce
que c'est que l'indépendance ça veut
dire que personne n'a dû pouvoir sur
vous cet immense comme conquête je ne
sais pas combien de temps il faudra pour
qu'elle soit faite je ne sais pas ce qu
en résultera je ne sais pas si c'est
forcément quelque chose qui tend vers le
bonheur des uns et le malheur des autres
c'est un autre problème je crois qu'il y
à une tentation général les femmes de
secouer l'état de dépendance dans
lesquelles elles se trouvent
et cela c'est entièrement commun pas
toutes les femmes et vous croyez qu'on
est en bonne voie
durand